toute manière j'aime beaucoup le cigare
c'est vrai et heureusement pour moi on
sait que marx et brecht adoré le cigare
aussi tous les matins à 11 heures c'est
une grande joie pour moi je prends une
passe de place de café je fais mon café
du café de l'intellectuel et je fume un
cigare beaucoup de musique dans le des
adolescents
je t'ai chiffres j'adore déchiffrer la
musique il a mangé plus le temps
maintenant mais tout de même j'arrive à
faire 10 en une demi-heure de piano tous
les jours ça remplace pour moi le sport
jamais fait de sport et ce à la même
fonction de délassement corporelle et
musculaires basque heureusement mon
enfance et de cette porte du luxembourg
jusqu'au coup de l'aller c'est à dire
jusqu'où lycée montaigne vous allez tous
les matins non seulement c'est là que
j'ai joué c'est là que j'ai fait ces
espèces de le sport sauvage qu'on fait
quand on est gosse mais aussi au fond
c'était un lieu d'amitié c'est là que
j'avais mes amis de lycée mes camarades
c'était l'espace même de l'amitié le
luxembourg c'est là par exemple j'ai
trouvé une fois mes camarades qui
faisaient l'école buissonnière et nous
étions sur ce banc et sa mère est venue
de rechercher ici je dis des choses
franchement je m'ennuie un peu au cinéma
je m'ennuie facilement aussi le reste de
mon activité m'oblige à réfléchir sur
des formes d'art en fait même un type de
réflexions souvent qui est de type
esthétique justement et je n'arrive pas
au fond à savoir moi même pourquoi je
sais pourquoi j'éprouve une sorte de
distance à l'égard de ce type d'image
qui est l'image mobile qu'est le cinéma
chaque lieu de sept chambres à une
fonction bien définie et c'est ça qui
m'aide à vivre effectivement j'ai le
coin où je peins le coin où j'écris le
coin je fais du piano et le coin aux
oeufs d'or
depuis quelques mois j'ai découvert une
autre activité qui est de peindre ou de
dessiner des mouches remy cet été et là
aussi j'en retire une très très grande
joie
dès que j'ai vingt minutes je mets des
couleurs sur du papier
si je puis dire chaque fois que j'avais
quatre jours et quatre sous j'ai essayé
de partir en voyage
et c'est ainsi en effet que j'ai
découvert le maroc qui est un pays
admirable à la fois par sa géographie
aussi par le charme la gentillesse de
ses habitants et par conséquent je suis
allé
très souvent au maroc qui a tenu une
place assez importante dans ma vie on
expliquer d'où tout de même que dans une
époque assez frivole tant de gens d'une
nouvelle génération
suivent l'ex passion des travaux et des
écrits comme les vôtres les étudiants ne
sont pas frivole l'espagne il ya chez
eux un grand une grande curiosité
intellectuelle et plus que cela une
sorte de morale de l'engagement de
l'engagement dans les idées l'engagement
politique ou idéologique ou contre
idéologique
[Musique]